we have brett saberhagen sitting right
here good to see you brett saberhagen
always good to see you
you got it Paul Rudd IREX all rod good
to see you host of the big slick along
with four of your good friends do you
would you like to describe to the radio
audience the hats that you are wearing
sitting next to brett saberhagen two
years old acclaim right that's right I
was two years old
clearly I was born in 1983 I found this
hat last week I was in a box of like
kind of hats that I had this was my hat
from 1985 which that obviously the
gentleman I'm sitting next to it's the
World Series 1985 with the riding
looking so old school like it would be
on the sheets that you used to sleep on
with all the other logos of the major
league that's right right uh-huh and
it's got the the Cardinals logo the
Royals logo and and the way it fits I
can tell it's from 85 the bands in weird
it isn't too high because it's so nice
always a weird thing when people have
the hats I think they just went up to a
little too high a mix of a top hat and a
baseball hat it looks good on you man
just resting on top now now no now that
looks fitting looks like what you warned
I know especially the fountains coming
out behind you in the window you have
the shot now Brett I know you were
before when you saw that we had the 2015
World Series fan of that one but I know
there's a where's that other one that
that the old guy the 1985 okay because
you are somebody has taken out your
trophy and we can replace 2015 one with
the night is the best Thank You Kurt I
just like to say and well what do you
think of this this one right here I tell
you it's an oldie but a goodie I'd say
it it brought bring always brings back
unbelievable memories you have this
place where Paul grew up is home away
from home for me
I get probably back to Kansas City
probably three four times five times a
year I've already been this third visit
this year already and it's kind of cool
Salvi and I actually did a little thing
a couple weeks ago raise the money for
the charity in that meet and greet with
the two World Series MVP Salvador Perez
correct yeah so they brought out both
trophies then and it's always good to
see salvie salvie is a great ambassador
of the game and a great player and loved
in Kansas City and again again because
we're trying to make sure you are happy
Brett says absolutely since Paul I know
that as they say in the game show
business but wait there's more what
isang nuke
Awards
we have those right here here you can
put them right here on the desk you
don't mind that's one look at this once
I never seen one of these in person si
uncle don't you worry you got him all
set all right okay you guys there you go
I think I'm gonna have to tip you very
well for all this I appreciate ya
so I'm loading the vault so you don't
get to keep these these stay here
replicas these are mrs. this is not a
replica those are rapid right okay but
Paul we have some nice parting gifts for
you a jar of Turtle Wax
you got a 1985 World Series hat
now is it true Paul that for that famed
game six that famed don dankinger call a
first base line right here in this here
stadium you were here for that game
we're two other hosts of the big that's
right we were we didn't know each other
then but we were all at that game I was
sitting right over there just opposite
the that just out third base behind the
dugout right and it was it was the
greatest game I've ever been to I mean I
was there and you know just recently too
but I never remember when that when they
won that game no one left the stadium
and I remember everybody hugging each
other and the stands and 20 minutes
later after the game everybody was still
there he's a huge fan though when we
first met was 2014 you know you were up
in the suite over there and somebody
mentioned hey
Paul's up there would you like to meet
him and I said oh yeah absolutely so
came up and met family and we've been
friends for a long time at a huge Royals
fan look at all the games yeah quite a
thrill to meet Brett first nice about to
say is that I know Yahoo and I saw him
say that I might give me a break even
CityVille
sitting here wearing my hat from the
series and sitting next to Brett say ray
and the trophy
yeah the two replicas of this I um it's
difficult to see you over these things
and who were the other two big slickers
hosts who were in the stadium at well
Sudeikis was there and Riggle was there
who had the best seats do we know where
the best seats I don't know you know I
had I had
pretty good I was a of that series I was
a I got to go to game two and Game six
and I had I guess my dad had some
tickets to Game seven but had given them
away so I didn't get to go to Game seven
and instead I had to work at a grocery
store
sacking groceries and nobody came in so
and but the boss but you were you were
bagging groceries bags groceries for
Game seven at work but not really cuz
nobody was even in the store every was
home watching the game but my but the
boss made me go clean the bathrooms
while he sat up front and watch the game
on TV and I didn't get even I'd come in
and check it and sounds like they're
happy job it was terrible what was your
boss's name what was his name was Ed and
I've called him out already on shows
because I never got over it
furious it's the worst thing to do to
somebody I come up I'd say what happened
he goes Darryl motley just hit a home
run don't and then and they go back to
the everyone else grab a mop go Jay go
go rearrange the milk well what was it
like around here Brett in 85 City you
know it was really kind of cool was the
governor's train from what I've been
told my mom was on it so it went from
Kansas City and right up to st. Louis
and so you went from towns with blue in
the Royals of course you know
everybody's wearing blue here and the
further you got towards st. Louis it
became a kind of a mixture of red and
blue you know the supporting and then by
the time you got to st. Louis it was all
pretty much red so the fans have always
been just tremendous fans here and I
don't know if since the stadium has
changed that it's a lot louder because
when I was here for 2014 playoffs in
World Series and then 2015 this stadium
is seems like it's so much louder maybe
because I was down in the thick of
things and they kind of kind of tone
that out a little bit but this stadium
was rocking in 2014 yeah
very loud and I know you went to some of
those games in New York too Paul I know
you were but you went to say no you
can't hear me over the award is getting
to some of those games in New York as
well I did I went
every game I went to everyone I came to
everyone out here in 2014 and everyone
in 2015 to em and playoffs I think he
had a little bit better seats let's put
it this way
you were not scrubbing toilets I was
definitely where was that was Edie here
I think might have been at Price Chopper
bagging groceries let's take one more
break when we come back we'll finish the
show with with Paul Rudd and Bret
Saberhagen Bret I do want to ask you
about the epidemic of strikeouts in
Major League Baseball that is happening
right now with May following up April is
the only months in the history of the
sport history of the sport where there
were more strikeouts than hits I just
want to get your two cents on that talk
a little bit more about big slick them
and send everyone on the road for the
rest of the day that's how we're rolling
here from Kauffman Stadium here in
Kansas City with a champion of the
Kansas City Royals next to the trophy
that he helped win in 1985 next to Paul
Rudd that's when we come back
but when we started this show in October
of 2014 I always thought like event like
this here it makes like is exactly what
a show that I wanted to be part of is
sports and pop culture and actors and
celebrities all coming together for a
charity event and I want to thank
everybody at AT&T when I said hey how
about let's give this a whirl and they
all say yes and they all said yes from
from Dan York and Jerry and a Gavino and
everybody back at the shop on down and I
just want to also give a shout out to
the technical crew Erik Jones Alan Guzzi
Kevin Thompson girl Katie Rambo TP
Barker Peter Smith the whole crew from
the Royals I want to thank Mike Swanson
Toby cook
Amanda Turk Issac rifle I hope I'm
pronouncing Isaac's name correctly
Melissa Blanchett from Aramark and from
the the big slick Tara Smith and Beth
poops today's guests as well
Frank Isola the daily news for calling
in Jake Tapper Will Forte Rob Riggle
David Koechner Eric Stonestreet Mitchell
Schwartz Charlie Day Adam Devon and the
two guys who were sitting here to my
left Paul Rudd and the man who has
signed in his World Series 1985 hat that
he wore when he was here in Game six
Brett Saberhagen thanks for guys being
there really one appreciates saying
thank you you got it so you saw on your
hat Paul I mean how about that I know
it's unbelievable what unbelievable if I
had told that young man who was up the
third-base line that he would be he's
got he's got a sign a bullet I would
have said who are you
that's your choice and why are you
talking to me he needs to sign a bowling
pin because he beat me in bowling last
year I had a really really good good
lead on them yeah and I think you last
for four frames all strikes and if I
turned around is like how did that just
happen it was the flu key as a fluke it
was total fluke look I had for some
crazy reason a really good game bowling
which I never do was a weird thing and
you were very careful on it'll happen
turned it on why do you think there's
all these strikeouts in baseball right
um everybody wants to hit hit homeruns I
you know it's funny I remember Steve
Boni I think oh yeah the the gentle
giants you know when I was playing with
him I think he led the league maybe once
or maybe twice and he hated it I mean he
had like a hundred and one hundred and
ten strikeouts I think he led the league
one year and a hundred ten strikeouts
and now they've got a hundred and ten
strikeouts by the break you know it's I
just don't get I can probably be a
strikeout pitcher nowadays instead of
more of a control pitcher well I think
part of its the shift to that
everybody's trying to hit it over and
and and not into it and and pitchers
know it and they throw faster and they
can throw more pinpoint may be high and
every strike it out it's just it's so
tough to watch some a and again you
don't have the guys that are you know
pitch efficient now to is because you
got the strikeout you get I see guys
after you know five innings they've got
80 something pitches you know and I used
to be able to get nine innings in with a
good 95 pitches less than I do you think
that is I just trying to throw the ball
as hard as they can not hitting their
spots not working ahead in the count
just yeah and I don't know maybe some of
it is with the switch you see it all the
time
who's the toughest sitter you've ever
faced Boggs he wore me out but he wore a
lot of guys out wait long he hit ya 360
lifetime for part of it was me big part
of it was me is that right yeah yeah I
bet yeah man I just you didn't stutter
Wade Boggs yeah yeah yeah which one red
sock ways bond so that yeah well I
remember one game when we were at Fenway
and I fished fish pretty good against
the Sox but it was one game I threw a
curve ball first first at-bat basic
second at-bat
fast ball basically third at-bat
changeup base it and I was like I looked
around I was like hey Bugsy I don't have
anything else to throw you shy just tell
you what's coming because throw the
kitchen sink out in three three at-bats
three hits on different pitches so he
wasn't just a fastball hitter just he he
was a hitter and who was who is the guy
I was Brett for you also Paul George
Brett was that the guy for you it was
hard to strike out for you who is the
toughest guy for you to strike down this
guy I could never get Brett out right
now I'll uh I'll well I loved all the
guys on the team I was a big Willie
Wilson fan like I really really liked
Willie Wilson as a kid and I loved Brett
too everyone loved Brevard I uh you know
there were a lot of guys Frank white
Amos Otis but Willie Wilson you know he
could run from home to third base like
nobody's business it was so pretty to
watch yeah Wade Boggs hit 450 in his
career against you breath 27 for 60 Wow
damn that's good
Paul god bless you and everybody the
part of big select you guys are all guys
to be here with you thank you very much
much for bringing the show here 40 no
please 40 people don't just drop what
they're doing with their families and
their business in their.what and come
hang out without you know you and
against Stonestreet Koechner Sudeikis
and Riggle showing the way I mean really
you guys you and your families who are
families organized and it's all nice and
it's we're incredibly thankful that they
come but when they all these people see
Children's Mercy Hospital and they see
the amazing work that this hospital is
doing I think that's another reason why
they keep coming back
it's pretty great well and thanks for
coming here Brett really appreciate it
you got it good job Mike and Chris and
thank you to hurt Lisa of the of the
Hall of Fame here in Kansas City Don
Bowie and sorry James Crittenden and
want to thank James for saying yes when
I said to James let's do this James is
like I am all in thanks to James back
home and Liz for doing her job right
here and getting all the guests and
booking the staff and also want to give
a shout out to Sydney Scott Stewart's
daughter graduated from high school
today at Miss Porter's school a
Connecticut it would have been a great
day for Stuart thank you everybody the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience